now back in september 2019
then candidate joe biden gave us a
glimpse at how he would manage the
southern border
what i would do as president is several
more things
because things have changed i would in
fact make sure
that there is we immediately surge to
the border
all those people are seeking asylum they
deserve to be heard that's who we are
where a nation says if you want to flee
and you're fleeing oppression you should
come
but despite the words you just heard
biden say he's adamant that his rhetoric
has
nothing at all to do with the current
crisis in fact the biden administration
has blamed everything from crafty
coyotes
to hurricanes to the previous president
and now democrats are
cracking out a new tinfoil conspiracy
and blaming the men and women
defending our borders according to the
daily independent former hud secretary
julian castro said
he wouldn't be surprised if the border
patrol union was colluding
oh there it goes again colluding with
republicans to undermine
biden because trump encouraged their
worst instincts and fostered a culture
of anti-immigrant sentiment
joining us now is hector garza national
border patrol council president
and stephen miller former white house
senior advisor to president trump
hector it's like blaming i don't know
like the fire department
after you set fire to your own house
it's their fault it's a fire
department's
fault for trying to put out the fire
your response to castro tonight
you know what this is just one more
example of the hypocrisy of the
liberal media uh pushing castro's agenda
and allowing castro to make basis
allegations without providing any type
of proof
now let's make it very clear we do not
dictate policy
with any administration under president
trump we had great dialogue
and we did provide advice to president
trump on board security issues
but we do not dictate policy he's wrong
well here's what i say stephen we have a
massive
humanitarian security
health and economic crisis all wrapped
into one
at that border what is the most shocking
aspect of what you're seeing
tonight on the border from what you're
reading and reporting
the most shocking thing laura is that
talking to
all of my sources at the department of
homeland security
border patrol and ice are releasing
the vast majority virtually all in fact
miners traveling alone and they're
releasing the vast
majority of adults traveling with
children across the border
you have border agents that are being
instructed
to literally drive busloads of illegal
immigrants
and release them into communities others
by the thousands are being sent to ice
not for being removed from the country
but to be put on what's called
adt that stands for alternative
to detention and that means that they're
going out into the community
they're just going to be released never
to be heard or seen from again
that is functionally by any definition
open borders that's a health crisis it's
an economic crisis
it's a public safety crisis and today
when majorca secretary of homeland
security
testified in front of the house and he
pretended
like his policies weren't responsible
for this crisis it was
a shameful lie it is a shameful lie
we're going to get to that that comment
during this hearing today that stephen
just referenced watch
the border is secure and the border is
not open we are not expelling
children who will arrive unaccompanied
without a parent or legal guardian
and we are caring for their custody and
their sheltering
hector he's once again encouraging
parents to send the kids
on this dangerous journey to our
southern border
meaning a lot of the parents are
probably in mexico or waiting
themselves to walk across the border or
to float across the border
and then to join their their children
here
isn't this just encouraging a huge
stream of multiple family uni
members coming across the border given
what he said
unfortunately i would have to disagree
with uh with secretary mallorca's
we do have an open border and we and we
do not have a secured border
in mcallen texas we have something
that's known as a temporary outdoor
processing site that's basically turned
into an illegal
entry port of entry where we're
processing thousands of
family units uh hundreds and thousands
of unaccompanied children
and we are releasing them into united
states now what's more frustrating is
that
this crisis is very preventable and it's
all due because of the
changes in in policy under the biden
administration
they got rid of the migrant protection
protocols
they got rid of the fact that uh miners
do not qualify for title 42 removal
and because of those policies now we're
seeing humans suffering on the border
and and we're frustrated and it's
definitely a crisis and
and those policies need to change but
everyone has to understand
that the men and women who are left to
clean up this mess
and to try to deal with the mass wave of
humanity coming into the country
are being demonized by the democrats led
by julian castro he is demonizing
law enforcement at our border border
enforcement i mean stephen
they claim to support enforcement law
enforcement officers public servants
no they don't they only they only
praise them when they're carrying out
their open borders agenda
but but stephen i have to ask you i have
to ask you one question i'm very
passionate about this everyone knows
stephen the idea that they are not
allowing
uh cameras or even some republicans
access republican office holders access
to these facilities
what does that tell you about what's
going on inside
it tells you that what is going on and
this is what all of my sources are
saying
is so much worse than anybody realizes
the volume of people arriving the
conditions the crowding
the unsanitary nature of how they're
being kept because of the coronavirus
and the number that are being released
is exponentially worse than
anybody realizes all because of biden's
policies
and one more thing laura every single
reporter in america should be asking the
biden administration
how many criminals have been released by
ice because of the memo shutting down
ice enforcement
my sources tell me that most interior
enforcement removal of criminals
has stopped that means dangerous people
felons misdemeanor convicts gang members
are back out on the street and reporters
need to get to the bottom of it
the american people have a right to know
american
american victims are just collateral
damage on the road to open borders
gentlemen thank you so much